Ugh. What are they doing?!
You might use them to help clear a trench,
but the main weapon you'd
use would be grenades.
I'm Alexander Watson.
I'm professor of history
at Goldsmiths, University of London.
I'm an expert on the First World War.
I've written three books.
And today we're going to
be looking at battle scenes
in First World War movies
to judge how real they are.
The Germans have really made a lot
of effort on their trenches.
They've brought their heavy
weaponry to defend the trenches,
but they've forgotten to
put any barbed wire down
at all in no-man's-land.
You would've had loads and
loads of barbed wire on it.
I mean, that's the key omission,
and it's a huge omission.
Of course, they've done
that because they want her
running towards them.
By 1918, the German army wasn't
simply composed of riflemen.
In 1918, if the German
army had been confronted
by an invincible female superhero
and they were shooting at her with bullets
and that didn't work, then they can go
to a light machine gun, an MG 08/15.
Or they've got a
minenwerfer, a light mortar,
7.58-centimeter mortar
that they can shoot at her.
So, full credit to
"Wonder Woman" for that.
These, kind of, shafts of
light that are being fired
are tracer bullets, or incendiary bullets.
And there were tracers used
in the First World War,
but they were mainly used
for anti-aircraft work,
and by aircraft as well.
They weren't used by
frontline machine guns.
They would expose your position,
which you really didn't want to do,
because you'd bring down
artillery and mortar onto you.
And second reason, it would
actually be a war crime.
Using incendiary bullets
against enemy troops
was a war crime by the
standards of 1914 to '18.
So it wasn't done.
There's another error there.
You've got a church in the background,
and that would be the first thing
to be knocked down by heavy artillery,
because it would be a
great observation post.
You just didn't have high towers
directly behind the lines.
Three out of 10.
Come on, push forward!
One thing that I do appreciate
about this scene is that
you do actually have an officer
attempting to lead the men
and keep some sort of control
and tell them where they're
going and direct them.
That's often forgotten.
Gas! Gas!
[warning gong chiming]
Gas!
OK, so this is all wrong.
I mean, firstly, who brings a warning gong
into no-man's-land when you're on attack?
You know, they did use
warning gongs to signal
that there was a gas
attack, but in the trenches.
Gas was used, famously,
in the First World War.
It was used from 1915.
They started with chlorine.
The Germans introduced
phosgene, which was more lethal.
It's pretty light, slightly yellowish,
so it wasn't that easy to detect, either.
But gas was an offensive
weapon, and that's because
both chlorine and phosgene
are heavier than air.
So if you're trying to take a trench,
then if you plaster it
with phosgene or chlorine,
that gas is going to
sink down into the trench
and then down into the dugouts as well.
Very, very dangerous for defending troops.
Against attacking troops
in the open, though,
you wouldn't use gas.
These troops are
aboveground, not underneath,
but the gas sinks down.
And your own defending
troops are, of course,
below the ground in trenches and dugouts.
So you're actually more
likely to risk them
rather than hurt the attacking troops.
Phosgene, for example, it was lethal,
but it took a few hours
for soldiers to get really, really ill.
If you're being attacked
by enemy soldiers,
really, you want an immediate impact,
before they get to your trench.
So as a result, you use shrapnel.
This isn't a plausible
scenario that we're watching.
The scene is implausible, but
we do get a really nice look
at a British PH helmet,
which was a mid-war gas mask.
Unfortunately, he's wearing it wrongly.
You need an airtight seal
for this to work effectively.
And the way that they did that was
they stuffed the bottom of
the mask down their collars.
And he hasn't done that, so
he's going to be in trouble
in a couple of hours' time.
This is really a three,
because they could at least
get the gas mask fitting right.
You know?
You can feel the power
of these 1918 Saint-Chamond French tanks.
And on top of that, I
love how they have them
looming through the smoke.
They're actually very
vulnerable to artillery fire.
And so what the French did was
they would put down a smoke
barrage, smoke shells,
in front of the tanks to obscure them,
and then they would come out
toward the enemy trenches.
And that's really,
really well represented.
So, there's problems as well
with how the Germans are behaving here.
The trench that they're defending
is actually a French trench,
and these French tanks
are counterattacking.
And the thing about
trenches is they were built
to defend one way.
So you'd have the fire step
opposite the enemy, facing the enemy.
You'd have the machine-gun emplacements
facing the enemy as well.
But in this trench, miraculously,
all of the fire steps, the defenses,
suddenly seem to be facing,
if you like, the wrong way,
towards the French counterattackers.
And it wouldn't have happened.
In 1918, if you saw
tanks coming towards you,
as a German soldier,
the first thing you do
is you get your flare gun
and you shoot a flare,
a signal flare, out over to
alert the artillery behind you
to bring down a covering bombardment.
That's your best chance of survival,
the best chance to hold a trench.
And there's nothing of that here.
By 1918, the Germans have
a number of nasty tricks
up their sleeves in order to fight tanks.
They've got light mortars,
so-called minenwerfer,
which can be turned horizontal
to fire directly at a tank.
They've even got specialized
anti-tank weapons.
They've got anti-tank rifles,
great, big, huge rifles
which would give this
13-millimeter shot out,
which could penetrate a tank's armor.
But these guys are just being presented
as pretty helpless riflemen.
Why would you stop and shoot?
These French tanks, they've got
a 75-millimeter cannon on them.
They're intended to take out strongpoints
and to take out artillery
which could be threatening the tank.
There's absolutely no reason
simply to shoot straight in
front of them at this trench.
There's nothing really
to be gained by that.
This is a 23-ton tank,
and it's got a 94-horsepower engine in it.
That's a smaller engine than
your average modern estate car.
And that's pulling this huge, huge weight.
And if you stop, you might get stuck.
The thing about war in 1918
is that you keep moving all the time.
You keep moving, or you're killed.
So, this tank appears to be
entering the trench network.
If a tank is that far
down, it's very unlikely,
especially with these ones,
which were very front-heavy
because of that big 75-millimeter gun,
it's very unlikely to get out again.
OK, now this is plausible.
If the tanks were separated
from their infantry,
then German defenders were
able to knock them out.
Now, what these guys are doing is,
they haven't got any
weapon which can penetrate
the armor of the track tank.
So they're going for what's
called a mobility kill.
They're blowing off the
tracks using a hand grenade,
which will stop it, and
then they're able to put
a hand grenade into
one of the firing ports
and blow the crew to
smithereens inside it.
That is how German infantry
combated tanks in 1918.
It was one of the methods.
OK, stop. [sighs]
Ugh. What are they doing?!
The French have come in.
They've got flamethrowers.
Flamethrowers were used. They
were used from 1915 onwards.
The Germans introduced them.
The French had their own
mobile flamethrowers as well.
They didn't carry a huge amount
of liquid. That's one thing.
And they weren't used in this way, either.
You might use them to help clear a trench,
but the main weapon you'd
use would be grenades.
But the bigger issue is
you wouldn't have them
in the first wave like this.
What these French guys are doing is
they are creating an
impenetrable wall of fire
through which no French troops can go.
Meanwhile, the Germans,
who are retreating,
are going to get away.
They're going to re-entrench,
and they're going to shoot everybody down.
The chaos and the fear,
there's a visceral sense here.
I mean, I think that is pretty realistic.
But this scene couldn't have
happened in October 1918,
and that's actually misleading people
about the end of the First World War.
The fighting that's being portrayed here
may well have happened
in the summer of 1918,
but for October 1918, it's gone.
The French and the British,
they roll 100 miles
in the last three months of the war.
This is really, really mobile fighting,
but it's just not represented here.
So I'd give this, at
most, a five out of 10.
So, here what we see is
Manfred von Richthofen,
the famous Red Baron,
the No. 1 scoring fighter
ace of the First World War.
He shot down 80 enemy airplanes.
And he's leading his Jagdgeschwader 1,
so his flight wing, fighter wing one.
And he was known as the Red Baron
because he painted his aircraft red.
This is his, I think, his
final aircraft, a Fokker.
Fokker Triplane, the most
famous aircraft he flew.
They did paint their aircraft
in these amazing bright colors.
The Germans had these wonderful reds
and yellows and patterns.
There wasn't any tactical reason for it.
It wasn't really about
recognizing other pilots.
Some people say that Richthofen
painted his aircraft
red to scare the enemy,
but really these German pilots
did it because they could.
They liked it. So they did it.
It does give a sense of the sheer chaos.
In 1918, a quarter of
the German air force,
of German fighter pilots,
are shot down and killed.
That's how lethal this type of combat was.
You would see scenes like
this in the Second World War,
particularly in and around,
I guess above, big cities,
with unmanned lighter-than-air balloons,
which were called barrage balloons.
And their purpose was
to force enemy bombers
to fly higher,
because otherwise, they'd clip their wings
and get knocked out of the air
by the wires connecting
these balloons to the ground.
You do get barrage balloons
in the First World War,
but there's not so much use of them.
You wouldn't have them strung along
the Western Front like this.
So what you'd see on the Western Front
would be observation balloons.
The purpose was to
see over no-man's-land into enemy lines.
They had baskets underneath them.
You'd have an observer with binoculars.
And around the tether connecting
the balloon to the ground,
there would also be a telephone cable.
And they were really, really important
in making sure that fire, the
artillery fire, was accurate.
So it was really, really
important to knock them down.
The thing is, is that
you'd only have two or three per sector.
Taking down these balloons
sounds like it should be pretty easy,
because they're full of
highly flammable hydrogen.
But actually, it was really difficult,
and it was really, really dangerous.
If you fired a machine gun
into one of these balloons,
it would pierce the balloon.
But the material was pretty tough.
And what you would get is simply
tiny machine-gun-bullet holes,
which a little bit of
gas would seep out of,
but not enough to bring the
balloon down in any way.
And it was very, very dangerous to do,
because around these
balloons on the ground
were anti-aircraft weapons,
and First World War planes are vulnerable.
They don't have self-sealing fuel tanks.
So if the fuel tanks get hit,
you've got petrol coming out.
They're made of canvas and wood.
It doesn't take a huge
amount to bring them down.
With these anti-aircraft batteries
directly below the balloons,
most pilots would steer clear of them.
Very, very dangerous
job, taking them down.
What this pilot is doing is firing a flare
at the balloon, a signal flare,
which then lights the gas
coming out of the
machine-gun-bullet holes.
Now, I'm really doubtful that
that actually would've worked.
It's kind of a nice idea,
but flares are for signaling,
and I think most likely
what would've happened
is that if you fired a flare
at one of these balloons,
it simply would've bounced off.
It's a bit of a mix there,
but I was pleased that at least they show
that these balloons
aren't easy to take down.
I'd give this a five.
There are around 85,000 Indian troops
who served on the Western Front
during the First World War.
And they often get ignored,
so it's nice to see that recognized here.
The British Indian army
sent over an expeditionary
force to the Western Front.
So in order to increase their manpower,
the British called over parts of
the Indian forces under their command.
Indian troops served on the Western Front,
actually, right through to 1918.
But the bulk of them in the infantry
were fighting on the Western
Front in 1914 and 1915.
And this shows an action
by the Lahore Division,
which had Sikh troops in it, in 1915.
Nice detail here, too.
This is a subedar-major.
Every battalion of Indian troops had one.
He was the highest-ranking Indian soldier
in an Indian battalion.
And these guys were very
well-respected soldiers.
They would've been long-service soldiers
in their 40s or in their 50s.
And you can see him
leading the soldiers on,
just as would've happened.
You have this aerial attack
which appears to come from behind them,
which in itself is odd,
by aircraft which are dropping bombs.
Now, there were ground-attack aircraft,
but not this early, in 1915.
There were aircraft which
dropped bombs behind enemy lines
on things like rail stations
and targets of military significance.
But this idea that you
had biplanes swooping down
at very low level and
attacking ground troops,
it just didn't happen in 1915,
not least because these aircraft
are very, very vulnerable.
They're very, very vulnerable to
machine-gun fire, rifle fire.
They're not moving that quickly,
and they're not armored.
So airplanes kept pretty high up in 1915.
This just simply wouldn't have happened.
The Germans seem to be
firing British weaponry.
There's a Lewis gun, a
British light machine gun,
that they're firing, and they,
the Germans did use
looted Lewis machine guns,
but not in 1915.
The Lewis machine gun
still wasn't on the front
at the time this is going on.
The mortar, I think, is
probably Second World War,
post-Second World War.
No one really knows. Even they
don't know what's happening.
Oh, oh, and then the
trench as well is rubbish.
You know, where's the parapet?
And where's the parados as well?
This is only going to
bother someone like me.
I appreciate that.
But it's, nonetheless,
this is not a good trench.
It's great to see Indian
troops represented,
but they could have actually represented
what these men went through.
This is just fantasy.
This is a one.
This clip portrays
the morning of the 25th of April, 1915,
when Australian troops stormed ashore
on what later became called
Anzac Beach at Gallipoli,
fighting the Turks, against
a small band of defenders.
Not quite as small as shown in this film.
There were about 90 of them.
They've got the landscape right.
It was only a small beach
these Australians ended up on,
and it was surrounded by high hills
with steep slopes and cliffs.
Attack!
The Turks only start firing
once the Australian
soldiers get off the boats.
Why would you do that?
The Australians are in boats.
They've got nowhere to go.
They haven't got any cover.
If they dive into the water,
they're carrying heavy packs,
they are going to drown,
and they can't do anything to you at all.
So if you're a defender and
you're facing an armada,
you start shooting before
anyone gets out of the boat.
In reality, the Turks
started shooting, of course,
when the boats came in rifle range.
The other big mistake
are these machine guns
in the bows of these landing craft.
You're going to hit your own people!
Clearly, you're going
to hit your own people.
Everyone is going to die,
and it's not going to be
the Turks who kill them!
One thing about this scene as well
is that it exaggerates the
bloodiness of the landing.
There were about 50
casualties on either side.
It wasn't as bloody as
is being presented here.
So,
a three.
My favorite representation of the war
would be "Journey's End."
Not so much for any
realism of battle scenes.
In some ways, that's
actually less important.
But just for how
it so realistically represents
the tension and the claustrophobia
of waiting for an attack
in the First World War.
Thanks so much for watching.
If you want to see more
videos in this series,
click on the link above.